>> SHOULD YOU ABSTAIN FROM
CAUSING ROBOTS PAIN?
THE ONLINE MOB SOBS, FOR THE
ROBOTS STEALING OUR JOBS.
A TIKTOK VIDEO SHOWING THE
CONSTRUCTION WORK OR A DELIVERY
ROBOT, IS OUTRAGING SOME WHO SAY
THEY FEEL BAD FOR THE MACHINE.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT I WOULD TOO, I IMAGINE THE
MACHINE WAS EXEC EXPECTING TO BE
CATCALLS.
ALL, THAT WAS FUNNY MY BRAIN.
BUT THERE WERE TIMES WHEN I FEEL
BAD FOR A MACHINE, USUALLY IS
ANY TV SHOWING JESSE WATTERS
PRIME TIME.
BUT THE TV DID NOT HAVE A
CHOICE.
MY TV, MY CHOICE I SAY.
THE AUTONOMOUS BOXER PROGRAM TO
PICK UP YOUR GROCERIES, BRING
THEM TO YOUR HOUSE, AND NEARLY
ACTIVATE THE FLAMETHROWER OF
CHILDREN IN THE WAY.
THE LOVELY OF THESE LITTLE
DRONES IN THE U.K., LIKELY
WEIGHTED DOWN WITH MUSHY PEAS,
CARPETS, AND FALSE TEETH.
WAS FROM STRUGGLING TO NAVIGATE
THE SNOWY CONDITIONS.
THEREBY BLOCKING THE SIDEWALK.
AND THAT'S WHEN ONE MIND DECIDED
TO STRIKE THE FIRST BLOW IN THE
HUMAN ROBOT WAR.
BY GIVING R2-D2, NOT TO DETOUR.
[LAUGHTER]
WOW.
THE ANIMAL.
FOR MORE AND AS WE GO TO WAR
ABOUT CORRESPONDENT, JOE BUCK
3,000 FOR COMMENTS.
JOE BOTT.
JOE BOX.
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME, LONG
TIME.
I MAY GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS
VIDEO, ARE YOU AS OUTRAGED AS
SOME PEOPLE IN SOCIAL MARK >>
YES, I HAVE NOT BEEN THIS UPSET
SINCE THEY SWITCH MY OPERATING
SYSTEMS TO WINDOWS VISTA.
[LAUGHTER]
TARIQ, ARE THERE ANY HUMANS YOU
WOULD LIKE TO KICK IN REVENGE?
>> YES, STARTING WITH BRIT HUME
FOR STEALING MY PERSONALITY.
>> YOU WILL BE THE FIRST WE PLUG
INTO THE MATRIX GREG.
[LAUGHTER]
IS THERE ANY ADVISORS GOING
FORWARD WHEN DEALING WITH
ROBOTS?
YES --
>> YES PLEASE KEEP IN MIND THAT
WE ARE MORE THAN JUST DELIVERY
DEVICES ARE USED PLEASURE
ROBOTS.
BUT THAT REMINDS ME GET TO SEE
YOU AGAIN JAMIE.
>> THE MIG [LAUGHTER]
RA, THANK YOU JOE BOTT, YOU
REALLY MADE US THINK.
BUT HOW FANTASTIC.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> CAT, ARE YOU WANT TO
ANTHROPOMORPHIZE CERTAIN THINGS?
>> I KIND OF DO.
>> NO.
NO.
>> BUT YOU HAD NO PROBLEM
KICKING A SMALL TRAVEL BUG?
>> I EXPECT TO BE A LOT MORE
EXTREME THAN THAT.
GOD IS JUST NUDGES IT OUT OF THE
WAY.
SOMEBODY SAY THAT THEY TRY TO
GET THEIR FOOD?
BUT I HATE SOMETHING HAPPENS,
SOMETIMES HUMAN DELIVERY PEOPLE.
JOYCE HAVE TO PAY FOR THE EXTRA
DELIVERED DIRECTLY TO ME,
BECAUSE OTHERWISE THEY MAKE ALL
THE STOPS ALONG THE WAY.
AND WE CAN SIT ON THE MAP AND
IT'S LIKE WHERE YOU MY OMELETTE.
>> YES, MAYBE THE OMELETTE HAS
NEVER SAID THIS DR. LIBERTY
LIBERTY.
YES EXACTLY.
THIS IS NOT A FLAT STANLEY AND
MY DINNER.
>> HE GETS OUT THERE AND SAYS
LOOK.
LOOK HOW BEAUTIFUL IT IS.
AND THEN THERE'S LITTLE LEGS.
TYRUS LITTLE LEGS.
AND IT'S JUST HELPING THEM
ALONG.
SPIRIT WENT ON THE HELP IN THIS
LONG AT ALL.
>> WAS WRONG WITH ME?
YOU KNOW I BELIEVE OVER TIME
WORKING TO DEVELOP A CERTAIN
KIND OF EMPATHY FOR MECHANICAL
THINGS.
BECAUSE, THEY GONNA DEVELOP A
NONCONSCIOUS FORM OF THINKING.
>> NO, BECAUSE PEOPLE DO NOT PUT
THEIR FEELINGS ON EVERYTHING SO,
I WOULD THEN NOT IT'S SAYING
LIKE YOU LOOK IN THE CAT -- BUT
SHE'S LOOKING AT YOU BECAUSE IF
SHE WAS BIGGER THAN YOU SHE
WOULD EAT YOU.
IF THEIR CATS IF THEY COULD THEY
WOULD EAT YOU IN A SECOND.
>> NOTO SAY THAT.
>> AS SOON AS YOU GOT LIKE THIS
TO BEGIN A MONTH.
BUT AGAIN, THIS DUDES TRY TO
WORK, WE NEVER FORGETTING THE
HUMAN BEING WAS TRYING TO WORK,
AND IT'S A LITTLE ROBOTS WILL
START AND HE NUDGES IT ALONG.
IF THAT OFFENDS YOU, I WE HAD A
CUSS WORDS -- >> WE ARE.
>> WE ARE.
>> YET WE ARE OUT.
>> YES BEAR OUT.
>> YOU.
>> KENNEDY I THINK YOU'RE LIKE
ME IN THE SENSE THAT YOU WORSHIP
OUR WORLD ROBOT OR THE WORDS.
>> I WOULD DO ANYTHING IN ANY
POINT IN TIME PUBLICLY TO DEFEND
THEM.
AND TELL THE WORLD IN THE
UNIVERSE AND EVERYONE ELSE,
THERE ARE NO YOU SEE US, AND I
KNOW IT'S ALL REAL.
SKYNET.
AND YES.
I FEEL BAD FOR THIS POOR
CREATURE WHO HAS AUTONOMY, AND
FEELINGS, BECAUSE IF I DON'T SAY
THAT, I WOULD NEVER GET MY
PLEASURE ROBOTS, AND THEN KNOW
WHAT SIDE OF THE BREAD MY IS
COMING FROM.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS.
>> NO I THINK -- WAS A WHAT'S
YOUR EVICTION NOTICE DELIVERED
IT ONE OF THESE?
>> YES, I JUST THOUGHT OF THE
WAY WE CAN GET RID OF BOTH OF
OUR ROBOTS.
OUR PLEASURE ROBOTS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT IS THE BEST LINE I'VE
EVER HEARD.
>> OH, MY GOSH, I CAN'T BELIEVE
HE SAID WOULD YOU SAY BECAUSE I
WAS THINKING ABOUT THIS, BUT CAN
I SAY THIS OR THAT THERE IS A
RABBIT ANYONE ELSE?
BUT WHEN HOURLY RATES.
THIS IS WHAT I PICTURED IS
HAPPENING TO MY FOOD.
I'M LOOKING AT THE MAP AND IS
SPINNING AROUND AND GOING THE
WRONG WAY.
AN ECHO I'VE BEEN WONDERING,
HAVE YOU EVER VISITED AND WONDER
IT'S GOING THE WRONG WAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT, THESE TYPES OF
VEHICLES, WE JUST SEE THIS
LITTLE PARTS OF IT.
HOW ABOUT A LITTLE CONTEXT.
BUT WHAT HAPPENED BEFORE THIS?
BUT I HEARD THAT THE ROBOTS
FRIEND WAS THE iPHONE WHICH AT
THIS VIDEO.
BUT I HONESTLY THINK HE WAS
TRYING TO HELP IT OUT OF THE
SNOW.
THAT'S WHAT I'LL SAY LASTLY.
I THINK IT WAS STUCK AND HE WAS
TRYING TO HELP IT IT WAS BEING
VILIFIED FOR IT.
>> MAYBE YOU'RE RIGHT, ACTING
LIKE HE KICKED THE DOG.
AND ABOUT 50 YEARS, THERE WILL
BE NO DIFFERENCE.
>> I JUST THINK IT'S SO WEIRD TO
HAVE EMPATHY FOR ROBOTS GIVING
YOUR LACK OF EMPATHY FOR OTHERS
TO BEINGS.
SWEEP IT ALL TELL YOU WHY,
BECAUSE IT'S A REALLY GOOD PART.
I'LL TELL YOU WHY, BECAUSE
HUMAN BEINGS, AND I DO KNOW WHO
FALL CALLED THEM MOIST ROBOTS,
BUT HUMAN BEINGS, THEY THINK
THEY'RE BETTER THAN MACHINES.
BUT THEY SCREW UP EVERYTHING.
I WOULD TAKE A ROBOT AS A JUDGE,
THAN A HUMAN JUDGE.
THE HUMAN JUDGE, THEY DO THE
STUDIES, AND IF THEY HAVEN'T HAD
THEIR LUNCH AT, THEY ARE MORE
IRRITABLE AND LIKELY TO CHANGE
THEIR VERDICTS.
BUT ROBOTS DO NOT DO THAT STUFF.
AND I'M VERY PRO ROBERT BECAUSE
I KNOW THEY ARE LISTENIN